Trascrizione: Sofia Jole Gelmetti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
12 dicembre 1969: bomba di piazza Fontana.
17 persone sono morte:
molti di questi erano agricoltori.
Uno di questi, il più giovane,
aveva solo 33 anni.
Questo era mio padre.
Nel '69, io avevo tre anni;
mio fratello Antonio aveva due anni;
mia mamma Annamaria aveva 28 anni.
Mio padre non morì
il giorno dello scoppio:
morì ben 16 anni dopo.
Lo scoppio bruciò le sue gambe,
riempì il suo corpo di schegge,
gli fece perdere l'udito.
Il papà era comunque
totalmente inabile al lavoro.
Con papà inabile al lavoro,
io fin da piccolo, con mio fratello,
mi dedicai alla gestione
della nostra azienda agricola.
All'età di 13-14 anni,
io e mio fratello eravamo già
due entusiasti, felici imprenditori:
ci piaceva fare quell'attività.
Di giorno lavoravamo nei campi,
e la sera giocavamo a calcio
nella squadra del nostro paesello.
Eravamo in una sorta di zona di comfort:
non chiedevamo nulla di più della vita.
Non chiedevo nulla di più,
tanto che non sentivo
l'esigenza di studiare.
Io fui bocciato in prima ragioneria,
con il sette in condotta.
Da ripetente, io fui di nuovo bocciato.
Io semplicemente non volevo studiare,
volevo fare l'agricoltore.
Dopo la seconda bocciatura,
a 15 anni, la mamma mi disse:
"Vai a trovare papà, ti vuole parlare".
Presi la mia moto,
andai a trovarlo in ospedale.
Mio papà mi chiamò
vicino a sé, e mi disse:
"Come puoi, Giovanni,
pensare che nulla cambi?
Oggi, l'agricoltura ti dà da vivere:
ma non sarà in eterno.
E soprattutto,
come puoi affrontare una vita
senza un titolo di studio?
Ti ho iscritto con la mamma
per la terza volta a prima ragioneria.
Per favore, studia:
ne hai tutte le capacità.
Fallo per me."
Pochi mesi dopo, era l'ottobre del 1983,
mio padre da quel letto spirò.
A quel punto, con un po' di impegno
e probabilmente di aiuto
da parte della scuola,
portai a casa quel pezzo di carta.
Ma nel frattempo, io continuavo a lavorare
con mio fratello nell'azienda agricola.
E in quegli anni,
la tecnologia, la meccanizzazione
stava trasformando il nostro business.
E lì si rivelò la prima
profezia di mio padre.
Ogni anno erano necessari
nuovi investimenti in macchinari.
L'azienda diventava sempre più piccola,
serviva nuova terra.
Noi non avevamo i soldi.
A quel punto, prima io e poi mio fratello
fummo costretti a uscire
dalle nostre zone di sicurezza,
e reinventarci.
La cosa curiosa della mia vita
è che sì, è vero,
la tecnologia allora ha distrutto
il mio primo sogno;
e oggi, dopo 40 anni,
io mi trovo a fare il manager
della più grossa azienda
di tecnologia italiana.
Quando, nel 2009,
io entrai in questa industry,
nel settore della tecnologia
e dell'informatica,
lo percepivo come un settore
al pari del settore bancario,
del settore farmaceutico,
di altri settori.
Mi sbagliavo!
Quello che ho capito,
lavorando in questa bellissima azienda,
è che la tecnologia non è un settore.
La tecnologia è trasversale, è pervasiva.
Non c'è oggi settore
che non sia interessato
dalle grandi trasformazioni
che la tecnologia sta portando.
Qualche anno fa andai in America,
in Silicon Valley,
a seguire una conferenza
sulle tecnologie esponenziali,
le tecnologie del futuro.
C'erano - eravamo 3000
in quella sala, da tutto il mondo.
C'erano bravissimi relatori,
bellissime presentazioni.
A un certo punto, sul palco,
ci hanno presentato
un timido ragazzo messicano,
che faceva il benzinaio in California.
Ricordo ancora nitidamente le sue parole.
Ci disse: "Guardate, io faccio
il benzinaio da tanti anni.
Per anni, tutti i weekend
ero abituato ad avere circa 4000 clienti
che venivano da me a lavare la macchina,
e a fare il pieno di benzina -"
aveva anche il lavaggio.
"Verso il 2010, la situazione
è cambiata improvvisamente,
e non capivo il perché.
Poi, parlando con i miei clienti,
l'ho capito".
Nel 2007 è nato lo smartphone.
Nel 2010 gli smartphone
si sono diffusi nelle tasche
di tutti i suoi clienti.
E questi non facevano altro
che pianificare in anticipo il weekend
sulla base delle previsioni
del tempo, accurate,
che trovavano sul loro smartphone.
E quindi decidevano se lavare
la macchina, e fare il pieno,
in caso di tempo bello,
o se starsene comodamente
seduti sul sofà di casa
a guardarsi la partita
di football americano, o di basket.
Capite perché la tecnologia è pervasiva,
anche nei settori
dove apparentemente non entra:
le pompe di benzina sono sempre le stesse!
la tecnologia cambia i comportamenti
dei clienti di quel settore,
e trasforma i modelli di business.
Guardate, lavoro
in un'azienda tecnologica:
e quello che vi posso assicurare
è che quello che abbiamo visto fino a oggi
è solo una piccola parte di un cambiamento
che sarà sempre più esponenziale,
nel prossimo futuro.
Questa è Xiaoice.
Xiaoice non è una persona:
è un avatar dotata
di intelligenza artificiale.
Ebbene, oggi in Cina Xiaoice
gestisce contemporaneamente i rapporti
con milioni di clienti:
ma soprattutto, nello stesso tempo
riesce a scrivere e cantare canzoni,
scrive libri per ragazzi, scrive poesie,
gestisce un programma tv
e gestisce 18 trasmissioni radiofoniche.
Be', pensate che XiaoIce prima o poi
non arriverà in Europa o in Italia?
Pensate che quello che è successo
a me nel settore agricolo
non succederà in altri settori -
o nel vostro, settore?
Cosa possiamo fare?
Ricordo la mia prima reazione,
quando ero agricoltore, al cambiamento.
La resistenza:
ma perché dobbiamo cambiare,
non possiamo aspettare un attimo?
Non so se vi ricordate,
alla fine degli anni '90,
i tanti miei amici agricoltori
che hanno bloccato l'aeroporto di Linate
per più di una settimana.
Ma prima di loro, ho scoperto
che un certo Ned Ludd -
era un semplice operaio tessile inglese -
ebbene, è passato
alla storia questo ragazzo
proprio per la sua opposizione violenta
all'introduzione delle tecnologie
che avrebbero distrutto posti di lavoro.
Lui lavorava nel tessile,
e lui si ribellò
all'introduzione dei telai tessili
che avrebbero meccanizzato
il processo produttivo.
Be', oggi, a distanza di tempo -
era la fine del Settecento -
il luddismo e il suo movimento
ha perso la sua battaglia.
È vero, la tecnologia
ha distrutto tanti posti di lavoro.
Però, pensiamoci bene:
lavori a basso valore aggiunto,
lavori ripetitivi, faticosi, pericolosi.
Ma soprattutto, nel lungo termine
la tecnologia ha creato nuova occupazione.
Nuova occupazione
a più alto valore aggiunto,
che ha saputo valorizzare
la creatività umana
e che ha permesso una grande evoluzione
dell'industria tessile.
La stessa cosa è avvenuta
in altri settori:
Io stesso oggi, a 40 anni di distanza,
vi assicuro che non ho nessuno,
ma proprio nessun rimpianto
dei tanti lavori che facevo
in agricoltura con mio fratello.
Lavori che facevo col badile,
e col falcetto, in mezzo alla polvere,
e che la tecnologia ha eliminato.
Allora, come ci poniamo?
È come se fossimo davanti a un bivio.
Da una parte, forse,
il rifiuto della tecnologia
non è la soluzione migliore.
Ma allora, come possiamo con serenità
aprirci al cambiamento,
ad accettare di uscire
dalle nostre zone di sicurezza
con l'aspettativa e la speranza
di rimanere rilevanti nel nuovo lavoro?
Con l'aspettativa e la speranza,
per quel che mi riguarda,
di mantenere un tenore di vita
che ci permetta di portare
i nostri figli alla laurea,
o di pagare un mutuo.
Guardate: io nella mia vita
ci sono riuscito
a reinventarmi, più volte.
E ci sono tre cose che ho capito
e oggi voglio provare
a condividere con tutti voi.
La prima la introduco con una metafora:
quanti di voi hanno imparato l'italiano
per poi diventare scrittori?
Una minima parte.
Per tutti noi,
l'italiano è stato una competenza
che ci ha permesso di accedere
ad altre competenze.
Io con l'italiano ho fatto ragioneria,
ho fatto altri studi;
non ho mai fatto libri.
Allo stesso modo, oggi,
io vi invito a vedere la tecnologia.
Non dovete pensare
che aprirvi alla tecnologia vuol dire
diventare sviluppatori di software.
No, oggi noi la tecnologia
la dobbiamo comprendere, studiare,
capirne i punti di forza e i limiti.
Non per diventare sviluppatori,
ma per comprendere
le trasformazioni in atto.
Per saperci muovere con agilità
in ambito digitale.
Noi siamo nati in un mondo
dove noi dovevamo conoscere i computer;
oggi entriamo in un mondo
dove i computer conosceranno noi.
Proviamo a cambiare
il nostro rapporto con la tecnologia.
La tecnologia, fino a ieri,
è stata per noi una semplice opportunità;
sempre di più, domani,
nel nostro futuro sarà una necessità.
Questo primo aspetto
ci porta subito al secondo aspetto:
che le tecnologie cambiano,
cambiano velocemente.
E allora, è necessaria
una continua capacità
di adattamento,
di evoluzione e di sviluppo
delle nostre competenze e capacità.
Quello che in inglese
chiamano "Re-Skilling".
Guardate, la mia generazione
è nata con l'idea
che la vita poteva dividersi
in due grandi fasi:
la fase dello studio, fino a 28 anni, 29;
e poi la fase del lavoro,
"mo' mi sistemo".
Queste fasi erano quasi sequenziali:
prima si studiava,
poi si lavorava per 40 - 45 anni.
Non è più così.
Queste due fasi, da sequenziali
devono diventare parallele e sovrapposte.
È impensabile, oggi, impostare
una carriera professionale
senza una continua attività
di manutenzione delle nostre competenze.
Quando smisi di fare l'agricoltore,
la mia azienda agricola
era vicino a San Donato Milanese,
vicino a Milano.
Vicino a San Donato c'è l'Eni.
Passavo con la mia moto,
mandai il curriculum,
mi chiamarono per un colloquio.
Ricordo ancora: ero un ragazzino,
avevo 18-19 anni.
Mi chiesero perché volevo entrare all'Eni:
risposi, in maniera forse un po' furbetta,
che volevo conoscere il mondo,
volevo conoscere il settore dell'energia.
Dentro di me, a quell'età,
l'aspirazione era un'altra:
io giocavo con mio fratello a pallone,
e il nostro campo di San Siro
era il campo di Metanopoli della Snam.
Il mio sogno era di giocare su quel campo,
non di girare il mondo -
sogno che poi sono riuscito a realizzare.
Questo ero io, a 18 anni.
Però vedete, quell'esperienza di lavoro
mi ha fatto capire
quello che mi disse mio padre.
Io ero stato agricoltore, per tanti anni,
e avevo un mio minimo di rilevanza,
nel lavoro che facevo.
In quella grande struttura,
ero una matricola.
Non riuscivo a incidere,
non ero rilevante.
E lì ho capito che per colmare il gap
con gente, semplicemente,
più brava e preparata di me,
io lì dovevo studiare.
E ho continuato a studiare,
e continuo a studiare tutt'ora.
E lì ho capito
che ciò che non si rigenera, degenera.
Però, vedete,
se tutta la vita dobbiamo continuare
a cambiare la tecnologia,
dobbiamo continuare a studiare,
ma che vita è?
Soprattutto se lo facciamo
con l'unica preoccupazione
di poter perdere il posto di lavoro,
è triste.
Allora c'è una terza dimensione,
molto importante,
che è la capacità di appassionarci
al lavoro che facciamo,
di appassionarci
alle aziende che troviamo,
alle persone che troviamo.
Soprattutto quando -
nella vita vi sarà capitato,
e capiterà a tutti -
incontrate quei maestri del sapere.
Sono persone di grande esperienza,
di grande capacità.
Innamoratevene, seguiteli,
fatevi contaminare dalla loro conoscenza
e alimentate la vostra
passione di imparare.
Avete capito che nella mia vita
queste tre cose -
l'apertura al cambiamento,
l'aggiornamento e la passione -
sono stati tre elementi
che mi hanno permesso più volte
di uscire dalle mie zone di sicurezza.
Sono stato: agricoltore;
impiegato; consulente;
oggi manager.
Ma in tutti i lavori che ho fatto
io sono sempre stato rilevante,
appagato dell'attività che facevo.
Queste cose io, però,
non l'avrei mai capite
se quel giorno, da quel letto di ospedale,
mio padre non avesse lanciato
quel salvagente,
dandomi fiducia
e spronandoli a costruirmi
una professionalità,
e a studiare.
Per questo io mi sento,
nella mia sfortuna,
un ragazzo fortunato,
più fortunato di tanti altri.
Oggi io avevo il piacere
di condividere con voi,
con i miei figli, con i miei nipoti,
quello che la vita
mi ha realmente insegnato.
Permettetemi però, anche,
di scusarmi con i miei ragazzi,
Federico e Sofia.
Voi siete qui a seguire il papà, oggi;
e oggi, per la prima volta, avete capito
che il papà non è solo quello
del 110 e lode alla Bocconi,
ma avete capito che il papà
ha avuto tante debolezze, come voi.
Il papà è anche quello
che è stato bocciato due volte.
che ha scelto il primo lavoro
per giocare su quel campo di calcio.
Il papà è anche quello
che solo oggi che avete 16 - 18 anni
ha avuto il coraggio di dirvelo.
(Applausi)
La vita riserverà a tutti noi
cambiamenti, difficoltà,
momenti di grande opportunità.
Io sono fermamente convinto
che un approccio aperto
e appassionato al lavoro
ci possa permettere,
qualsiasi onda affronteremo,
di surfare sui cambiamenti,
affrontando con fiducia e positività
le sfide che la vita ci riserverà.
(Applausi)